So yesterday there were some really interesting
moments during Donald Trump's corona virus
press briefing.
One of them was when within minutes Donald
Trump went from saying, I'm withholding money
from the W.H.O. to denying that he ever said
that.
We already looked at that.
I mostly have not been playing clips from
these press briefings each day, because if
I did, the entire show would be clips from
the press briefings which have essentially
replaced Donald Trump's political rallies
in the era of Corona virus as a way for him
to get out his propaganda.
And he probably to some degree kind of like
gets off from doing these press briefings
would be my guess.
But yesterday, there were a couple of things
that I really want to highlight, because they
go beyond the Corona virus story alone and
they bleed over into some other important
issues, one being the November of 2020 election
and how to do it safely.
And the idea of voting by mail.
Now, Nancy Pelosi has already said we should
vote by mail in 2020.
I played that clip for you last week.
Coronavirus makes it dangerous for people
to mass gather at polling places.
Although we are expecting a decline starting
very soon, that will go through July August.
We're not exactly sure until when in November
we will likely be in the second wave of Corona
virus cases.
But Donald Trump has been very critical of
voting by mail.
Why?
Well, we know why he admitted it, because
it would help Democrats win.
And you don't have to take my word for it.
Here is Trump himself saying that exact thing.
Just last week, I will tell you this.
If you look at before and after the things
they had in there were crazy.
They had things, levels of voting that if
you ever agreed to it, you'd never have a
Republican elected in this country again.
They had things in there about, you know,
election days and what do you do and all sorts
of clawbacks.
And they had things that were just totally
crazy and had nothing to do with the workers
that lost their jobs.
All right.
So we know Trump knows voting by mail would
be bad for Republicans.
It would be bad for him.
So yesterday during the coronavirus press
briefing, he again went on about how vote
by mail is bad.
Vote by mail is corrupt.
Vote by mail is fraudulent.
But a reporter accurately pointed out that
and this was being carried live on Fox News
and on other networks.
Mind you, a reporter points out, wait a second.
Mr. President, you voted by mail in Florida
just a few days ago.
If it's so bad and corrupt, why is it that
you're doing it?
And Trump says the quiet part out loud, admitting.
Well, it's OK for me to do it.
It's just not OK for other people to do it.
Take a look at this video.
You were highly critical mail in voting, failing
your mail in ballots for mail and anything
as voting rights erupt in Florida's election
and last month.
Sure, I could vote by mail first because I'd
love to.
Well, that's called out of state.
You know why I voted?
Because I happen to be in the White House.
So they will be able to go to Florida to look
at me.
Just a mailing.
Well, there's a big difference between somebody
that's out of state and does a ballot and
everything sealed, certified and everything
else.
You see what you have to do with the certifications
and you get thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebodys living room signing bell
mail in voting is horrible and corrupt, but
I'm allowed to do it.
Trump clearly imploding here and tries to
wildly suggest, well, you know, I'm doing
it from out of state and all of these other
people are talking about doing it in-state.
All else being equal, though.
Isn't it safer to do in-state man vote by
mail because the ballots have to travel ashore?
A smaller distance, a shorter distance.
Doesn't that I mean, it's like it's not really
a big difference, but it seems that if anything,
vote by mail within the state is less risky
than what Donald Trump is doing.
It's absolutely and completely incoherent.
And I'm actually surprised Fox News didn't
cut away from this altogether.
Mail in ballots are good and convenient for
Trump, but they're bad for everybody else.
Now, if we had a reasonable president, if
we had a real president at all, I think maybe
it's more accurate.
The president would realize we have a pandemic
and a top priority is we need a safe option
for voting.
It should be transparent.
Vote by mail is not corrupt.
Let's start now or really weeks ago setting
up a vote by mail in every state for everybody
for November.
But Donald Trump has already admitted vote
by mail would be bad for him.
It would be bad for Republicans.
And he's right about that.
Why Democrats are more likely to believe the
science on Corona virus.
Republicans are more likely to repeat to believe
Donald Trump's propaganda.
Democrats are more likely to heed warnings
about social distancing.
So if November comes around and we're in wave
two of the virus and things are dicey, there
is no doubt that Democrats are more likely
to stay home than Republicans.
If everyone has a safe, convenient, secure
way to vote from home, Trump realizes accurately
it's not good for him.
That's why we have what we have today, which
is Trump calling vote by mail, dangerous and
corrupt.
But of course, he's doing it.
And the only way in which voting by mail is
dangerous is that it makes it more likely
Trump is removed in the fall, which we desperately
need.
And Trump is increasingly desperate to prevent
very, very difficult stuff that we are dealing
with.
And these are some of the side stories which
aren't even really side stories that really
deserve a lot of attention.
We'll have more on this and today's other
stories on the David Pakman show Instagram
page at David Pakman Show.
Do me a favor while you're there.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
You may not have heard I am now the poster
boy for a hair project.
You'll know what I mean if you check out my
Instagram at David Pakman.
Quick break